[Inaudible].
Yeah, I can see, but I think that I totally agree with you on, on,
especially on where you have lower, very low income and large difference.
Some of the African countries totally agree that, uh, you can't, uh,
house, uh, the Fort is controlled on the few hands.
Obviously it should be distributed. Uh,
well then we on the region fund is distributed to everybody area,
all are part of it. Uh, but, but the sad thing is it's a,
it will never grow up in forever. It is obviously because the oil will be, uh,
uh, there is, uh, or, or it will be gone, but, uh, but, uh, then again, it,
I think the vital point, or this is, um, uh,
what's critical and I don't argue the, at all, uh, you know,
the history because that's very well addressed as very well addressed. Um,
and, uh, it's time that somebody that does it,
but what I think you would want should emphasize is what
system create jobs because creating jobs, great welfare.
If everybody, if certain, uh,
it might be, you should actually accept that people that work very hard are,
have a payback on working hard, that you should accept.
It's a very wrong if you, if you, uh, do it like you did in, uh,
in China, [inaudible].
I don't think this is the main risk in Europe today. No, China.
Just taking, uh, the example, that's an extreme example.
So I, I totally agree with it, but that's, that's,
that's the way you should never do it. You should,
there is all this basic for this.
You should always have a system that you
get return of the job you do. If you've worked very hard,
you should have a return of it. If you, if people doesn't have a return on it,
they will not work very hard. And it gets people to start working.
It will motivate and motivates people.
I think the solution is two policies. I'm just curious. Well,
I think you need to find some, some balance, you know, again, Windsor,
very I income and wealth group sometimes are able to do a fiscal
optimization so that they pay less than the middle class. You know,
I think this is too little. And you know,
when Warren Buffett with the top U S billionaires will be Gates says that he
pays less tax than his secretary. Yeah. I think this is a problem.
So global tax, well, you know, let's start with, uh, you know,
European countries.
I think if you take European countries and the corporate tax in Europe,
you know, I think that if we don't coordinate, uh, we will end up with, uh,
you know, 0% corporate tax, just like in a written stacks now it's okay.
You know, I would like every tax to be zero,
except that we have to pay for schools and our social models.
So then we have to overpack someone and, you know, overtaxing, labor,
captive, labor income, and consumption the way we do. I, you know,
I don't think that's good for job creation.
So you need some level of inequality to motivate a manager. That's for sure.
Now,
is it useful for the economy to pay top managers
in the financial sector or other big companies, 10 million euros per year,
instead of 1 million? You know, I couldn't find it in the data. You know,
I couldn't find in the data, the extra performance,
the extra drug creation that you would expect.
So of course you need to pay managers well,
but the idea that if you just pay them 500,000 euros and nobody will
accept to work because it not works working out for that,
and you need to pay 10 million, but you know,
the inequality we are talking about today, you know, it's, it's a, you know,
you have very large groups. Uh,
if you take in the U S which is the most extreme case you have about
70% of total us economy grows between 1980 and
2015, which has gone through the very top income groups. Now,
given that the growth of wealth, this period was not so good. You know,
1.5% per year in per capita,
if you have 70% of that going to the top,
everybody now in the U S agrees that this has contributed to the stagnation
of Midian. Uh, I was all income. You know what the bottom 50% is getting.
And in the end,
this also contributed to the rise of household debt and this contributed to,
to fragilize the economy system. So it's okay to have, you know, rich people,
middle people, poor people,
but you need everybody to grow more or less at the same speed in the long run.
I totally agree with you. But on the other hand, yeah, I totally agree.
And take as an example, I'm not, I'm thinking I'm even not even among the 10th,
highest paid in Norwegian. A lot of pilots are pay more, earn more than I paid.
That's the paycheck, right? That's the paycheck.
But if you're starting out the shares, the shares, okay. But then again,
I paid 10 times as much tax as I earn.
Correct. Is it.
Pay 10 times as much tax? So you pay a 90% tax rate.
No, I paid, I paid 1000% tax rate.
So what I have to do, I have to sell off things. So of course,
out of the things that you create, is it the right?
So what's your tax rate as a fraction of your wealth? Well, tell us,
what's your waste? What's your tax.
It's now.
So what's your wealth.
How much is your wealth and how much is your tax each year? That we can.
10 Times that what I have in totally trouble.
But you're not answering my question. So what, how much is your wealth,
your networks today?
And my net worth depends on the shares on the.
Value of the case with the market value of today.
Although then I know I'm on a,
the shares are going down to the strikes on the way I'm on the wrong side.
[inaudible] New phone number, but it's negative four for this year.
It's been negative because I bought, I still pay attention.
Your network is negative.
And no, but the value has gone down.
I understand it has been done, but what is this value now?
Uh, then I have to multiply with the share. Uh, I actually say it another way.
I don't care about what, uh, what I.
Oh, it was
terrible.
I'm just trying to get a sense of what's your wealth, what's your tax,
so that we can all have a sense of what's going on. You know,
I don't know what John said, but.
Tell me, how can we do all this, the market [inaudible] it's in the stock,
uh, on the stock exchange is the, it's a, it's a company on the stock.
It's the value on the stock? [inaudible] ballpark figure.
It would be 1 billion, two billions on your work.
Okay. So let's say when billion to make a simple number, now, what's your tax.
What was your.
Interesting times as much as, uh, aside, uh, can you give us a number?
No. If, if this is amazing, you know,
I just say.
I, I don't, I don't even, uh, I'm not even in the range of it, uh,
say I'm, I'm, I'm a couple of hundred thousand dollars, but then I,
you pay a $2 million in tax, right.
Okay. But 2 million out of 1 billion normally commute.
So this is an average tax rate on your, you know, I don't know, I'm just,
I don't want to, you know, to overdo it, but you know,
when we're in perfect with a billionaire in the U S when we're in
perfect did the same computation and he did it, right. He did it until the end.
We computed these Wells, which was more than 1 billion, you know,
it's like $50 billion and he computed total tax
and is compare, you know, the tax rate and compared with the secretary,
you know, this was less, but, you know, I don't know in your case,
but I think it's important to put these numbers into the public
domain and public scrutiny so that we can all make an opinion. And, you know,
I'm not saying, I don't know.
I think we need transparency about this, you know, so that we can,
we can have an opinion.
And I think everybody should pay tax, but I think it's,
if you give away whatever you are and that's, that's a, it should be.
I'm not saying that, you know, but.
Who decides what you are to earn is.
You to you, you decide that yourself. I, I.
I mean, that's, I.
Don't think he is correct. And I totally agree with it's. Uh, this is, uh,
the woman, a CEO, shouldn't earn a lot more than the rest of the day.
It should be on the same level as, as, as the top manager. If we.
If we take the words of in the world today,
according to what magazines are doing, and, you know,
you have different magazine, Asia,
Forbes magazine at the world level for world billionaire or different magazines
in different countries, no, in Sweden, in France.
And they all find more or less the same thing,
which is that if you look over the past 20 to 30 years and you take your fixed
fraction of the world, population has the top. And you look at our average,
well, since this group has been rising,
so people above when the underlying wealth on average is,
has been rising at six, 7% per year in real time. So you have,
some people will go down. Some people will go up,
you have some mobilities and renewal of these group, of course,
but taking into account those who go down, those who go on average, the average.
Well, so the group is going up at six, 7% per year. In real terms,
in the top of inflation. Now this is perfectly fine,
except that average wealth in the world and average income is going up at one to
2% per year. So in terms of tax rate,
you can see that if you have a wealth tax rate of 1% or
0.5% or 1.5%, and if you grow at six, 7% per year,
on average, that's not going to make Metro for different.
So I know this can seem like a big tax to you when you make the check.
But when you look at the overall equilibrium for the entire society,
you still have increasing concentration in the top 12 groups,
which at some point we'd have to stop.
But don't you, don't it? Sorry, I can't answer that. No, I,
I agree with you shouldn't make the different speaker.
You should think about job creation, how to create Trump, because it
doesn't have a point there that you focus very much on the inequality and the
inequality as a problem, but isn't, isn't the most important thing to, to, to,
to actually lift poor people out of poverty.
And of course the problem in your book,
I see the problem that's being, we have these super rich people getting richer,
but it's, is that really the problem? No.
You know, I care a lot more about the pros and about the region in my book,
I try to compare different societies over time by looking at
our bottom Alfin society. So I look at different groups.
I look at the bottom 50%, the top 10%.
And in that the top one or two,
and then the middle 40% who are not in the bottom RF and not in the top 10 and
which I call the middle-class patrimonial middle-class in my book.
And what I really care about is the share,
going to the bottom 50 in the middle 40, more than the, than the top in itself.
Now, the problem in practice is that if you want to finance the
investment in education in infrastructure,
which is really what can help you to reduce inequality and to get the button to
move up, you also need tax revenue,
and you also need an equitable tax system because our social contract in,
in Europe and in many parts of the world relies on the view that, okay, we,
we pay a lot of tax to pay for public and education and earns,
but we all pay a lot of tax. And if we have groups at the top,
we're able to negotiate a 0% tax rate on what they get, because,
uh, basically there's competition between countries to attract them. I think,
in the long run, this can, Danja our social consensus.
And there's a risk that many people in the middle or in the bottom feel,
okay, well, you know, if the top people are not paying, you know,
I don't want to pay and they will go for selfish solution. You know,
when you don't manage to solve your domestic inequality problem in a peaceful
manner, you can always find other people to blame. You can find foreign workers,
you can from foreign countries. And, you know,
I'm very concerned about the rise of nationalism and populous movement can,
which, which, which can be a consequence of this.
And can, can this just information how much the, the, the, the,
the top 1% is worth it, can that also be fuel friendly.
Can also be fuel.
For envy. I mean, because it creates,
I mean like your book maybe can, for some.
I don't think people are motivated by envy. You know, I think the problem again,
is when you have all this news report saying that multinational
companies are not paying any corporate tax anywhere in Europe.
And if you have a small and medium sized company and you're paying 30%,
40% tax, and you ears at large mature of being one or two,
that it's not a point of envy, it's just a problem of, of basic fairness.
Don't you think we need values here, values from leaders that say, Hey,
you know, if we have this huge multinational company, why should we pay 0%?
We come down to the values and,
and making a difference in the business world where businesses, as,
as leaders can be responsible and say, you know,
let's be equitable or let's give back, or, you know,
Norway has got this huge fund. What can we do to get rid of it?
Not necessarily get rid of the whole thing, but, you know, do something where
she has. He got the point here that, that it's, it's, it's very different,
how people are rich. I mean, you have, you have, uh, you have people that,
that use their wealth to buy Ferrari's or,
or fancy yachts, you know, and you have people that, that choose to,
to, to start charities or give them their money away.
It's totally different way of being well. No, you're right.
I had this fascinating discussion with bill Gates a couple of weeks ago,
and he wanted to write a review on my book. So he told me, okay,
we need to have a CLU Skype conversation before I write my review. So I say,
okay, let's do that. And he said, okay, I love your book.
Inequality is a big problem, but I don't want to pay more tax, basically.
That's precisely I don't care. Right?
No, he came with actually a solution, which is close to what you said here,
which is he say, okay,
I'm ready to pay 90% tax on very high consumption.
So if you consume a lot, then you should pay a lot of tax.
But if you just give your money away, should not. Now the problem is, you know,
what's consumption, you know, in the U S for instance,
you have all these billionaires, we are giving this money to political
action committee, to political parties. So, you know,
when the curse browsers was, is rapidly, very, you know,
very Republican billionaires were founding the tea party, you know,
when they are giving money to this, you know, it's this consumption, you know?
So when, when you're very wealthy,
you cannot just consume very much on food or clothes. You know,
you very often you consume, uh, influence or power. So you consume, uh,
some time practitioners or journalists academics. And, and so, you know,
the progressive tax on consumption ID, I think as limits. And, and also,
it's not easy to see what's personal consumption. You take your corporate jet,
you know, this,
this personal consumption is this investment from your company account.
So I think Netwealth is a much better indicator of your ability to
contribute to the common. Good. And then if you want also to give to charities,
if that comes on top of taxation, then that's perfectly fine, but you cannot,
it's very difficult to organize society by letting people decide
themselves how much they want to contribute for the common. Good.
Well, one final question since your book came out, uh, it's been, uh,
it's been debated a lot on, um, on the, um,
discussed a lot and even criticized by, by, uh,
quite many, uh, um, I wonder,
has that changed your views because it's based on, this is an ongoing research.
I mean, it's not, it's not conclusive, uh, has that,
that has these discussions changed your views?
Yeah,
it probably is to me the most positive impact of the success of the book and the
publication in the book. And now more than 42, a long way,
Jesus is that it induced in many governments in several countries to
open their fiscal data and their fiscal archives in a way that
they did not open before. So if I was to rewrite the book today,
I could include a new countries in the book, like in Korea, in Taiwan,
in Brazil, in Mexico. Uh,
they did not to open the data before and after the publication of the book,
many journalists, like you asking the government in Brazil, okay,
why are y'all not in the book? And, and now they are opening their data sources.
So this is an ongoing process, as you said, you know,
the data we have collected in the book is imperfect. You know,
it is much more than what we had before, but it is still too little.
And so this will continue and we have a website, uh,
the world wealth and income database,
where we will keep online as much data as we can.
And then people can draw a different conclusion. Let me say very clearly,
we are in the area of social sciences. And, you know,
I don't pretend that the conclusion I drew from my historical findings
as the only possible conclusion.
So I have no problem with disagreement and discussion. And, you know,
this is why in the end, I'm interested in these issues about money.
Everybody has a strong, and.
That's why has that been,
has that been irritating sometimes for you that the left side of politics has
hugged you so much? They, they, they totally love you.
Uh, well, you know, there are some people on the right who like me as well,
you know, look, this is not a book for,
for the left or book for the right. You know,
this is a book for people read books and, you know,
for people who don't read books, there's nothing I can do. But, uh, uh, it's,
uh, uh, you know, I think if you open the books,
you will see first that it's very readable. You know,
this can be read absolutely by anyone. It's a bit long.
I am sorry about these very heavy, very
history of income and wealth, uh,
since 18th century in over 30 countries. So this is a long story,
but this is readable and then people can make their own mind about the future.
And, uh, you know, I, uh, again, I have no problem with disagreement.
I'm not member of any political party and, and, uh, you know,
anybody can rule conclusion.
Thomas Piccadilly. Thank you so much for being here. Please.
Welcome professor Thomas Piketty.
[inaudible].